Le Mouvement Démocrate est
un mouvement à taille humaine.
Je m'appelle Anice Mouaddel, j'ai 36 ans.
Je suis né à Ollioules, dans le Var.
Après des études de droit à la fac de Toulon
puis à la fac d'Aix-en-Provence,
j'ai été juriste d'entreprise au sein
d'un Cabinet d'experts comptables.
Aujourd'hui, je suis attaché parlementaire depuis 2017,
pour un député MoDem : Mohamed Laqhila.
Mon parcours militant a commencé très tôt.
C'est depuis 2012,
lorsque je me suis rendu compte
que la plupart de notre jeunesse
n'avait absolument plus confiance
en la politique.
J'ai alors décidé de m'engager à un niveau local,
pour me rendre utile d'abord,
et aujourd'hui,
je suis conseiller municipal
depuis 2015 pour la commune de Bandol.
Suite aux élections municipales partielles
qui sont intervenues en décembre 2015,
notre liste a de nouveau été élue.
Je me suis vu confier la délégation
de la politique en faveur de l'emploi
et la première des choses que j'ai constatées,
c'est que les entreprises Bandolaises
étaient beaucoup trop éloignées
des demandeurs d'emploi bandolais.
Fort de mon expérience politique
et cherchant à trouver
une famille politique avec des valeurs
et un engagement qui soient sincères,
j'ai rejoint dès 2018 le Mouvement Démocrate.
Le Mouvement Démocrate est d'abord
un mouvement qui a des idées
qui sont pour moi en équilibre.
Ni trop de droite, ni trop de gauche.
C'est ce que la politique
aurait dû être depuis toujours.
Le Mouvement Démocrate est par ailleurs
un mouvement à taille humaine.
C'est-à-dire que lors de certaines réunions militantes,
lors de certains événements publics,
on se retrouve tous ensemble,
des pontes, des moins connus
pour discuter de choses réelles
de la vie quotidienne.